well hello reject nation I you know my
name and you also know mine it we don't
treat our videos as if you're new to the
channel this is Kerry Nemiroff though
they might have known my name but I
guess it's better to point it out hey
Kerry
have you seen a little independent movie
guardians of the galaxy oh yeah yeah I
don't know if you've heard of it trauma
guy maybe do you know that my favorite
MCU movie is guarding to the galaxy one
what is an MCU oh I can't man and yeah
Green Lantern okay well how it should
have ended have you ever seen their
channel no you've never seen it's so
fine Jon Roca to how it should have
ended and I'm going to introduce you
guys the galaxy vol 2 got a plenty of
requests to check this video out so many
of those you got to watch this excuse me
I might have one you probably have there
one guys the last time at oh yeah one of
the biggest yeah now that I think about
it if you pay attention to the name of
the channel it will clue you in to
what's about to patron the day shout out
today for Rosa para sure you guys have
heard of her before we rode the who
talked about her on this channel but
today she is our female subscriber the
one whole time
[Music]
yes I have some more
top well the ruins for fun
make it to let our matrix you showed me
the last I heard
I see how it [ __ ]
yeah that's pretty good beta do you
slide on your shoes
so whatever you do don't push this but
[Music]
who will get it about to be here telling
me you wanna buy some batteries
[Music]
okay we all agree rocking out up some
kids absolutely stories okay after all
these years I found you and who the heck
are you well I thought my rugged good
looks what I giving me away under dad
Peter so this is one movie is it so
everyone Peter these new balloons
she actually didn't even really do
unless another who whoa hold on that's
that's not what I'm trying to do holy
crap
Darth Vader is real what day the name is
David Mason David I play come out of
your plate hahaha you don't eat weird to
get invited onto a ship and they
immediately go take a nap
[Music]
hahahaha you know at first I thought I
should shout down there really obvious
like give away my position whatnot but
then I thought man just shoot him now
you know ha ha ha look cute on the
counter that nutrient I know
boy that was dumb sure would for us
luckily I'm really really
[Music]
[Music]
wait Peter hold on a second hey what you
doing with that bomb bearing in my brain
[Music]
so that I won the fight in my extension
idea that I have to take off but now I'm
currently taking over the entire
universe okay so you guys might want to
get going what one wrong move here we go
[Music]
target one like a fortune laser million
freaking arrow yeah I just want to know
specifically arrow
[Music]
[Music]
Gregg you really done that beautifully
do we blow up my father because he was
evil and insane an awful planet you know
hell and also survive though you killed
your own father
that's crazy no he was crazy I decided
amending my father he wasn't my dad
childless manly when you say yeah I
realized that now sorry well we're
serious well the REA for everyone in
there dad you know some of us never had
like the talking puppy I too never
moment I knew my father extremely well
he was a Love Machine and would tell us
stories about it Rick you know ask me I
know your dad was a horn boy he had some
kind of dad my father's probably gonna
kill every one of us I asked you dad as
well if I could I would have tried to
say you look Lovejoy unicornia dude I
thought you were asleep
what things also still with me I think
camera tots I heard it was also still
listening because of thing Batman one
Mir Papa job
cool my name Hey Wow
ha iris mom it was real what
MARY POPPINS is a woman good job guys
yeah where's your post rattling ah so
predictable when they see what I've
created here
[Music]
that was really stereo man they pointed
out some things that I've definitely
thought about like when when rocket is
walking away from the gold people and
he's whispering so loud they attract
yeah yeah that was a great mode you can
I like the way they play that like Roger
totally got himself killed right good I
felt like all that stuff at the end
happened with all those gold people
attacking because of rocketed he
suffered no repercussions for that he
didn't seem to feel any guilt well it
was we're having the movie be like no
that was there still our protagonist the
way they gotta kill uncle yeah why I get
what a goalkeeper remember yeah robbers
are actually watching - I never
I can't believe actually that I've never
made the connection between ego and yeah
yeah yeah really yeah they're very
similar yeah surprisingly similar yeah
they're so good though I feel like now's
the time I'm gonna be like oh like these
were great guys I'm going to go home and
I'm gonna watch their channel and then
I'm gonna come back next time be like
voiceover actors they get are great no
the guys does Michael Rooker sounds so
accurate like it everyone else do rocket
sounds really good Chris Pratt's a hard
boys to nail down but it's passable he
really gets hard to nail down but as
long as like you get the cadence of a
voice you can kind of make it work
absolutely and I think they definitely
have that here I didn't think about with
all the gold people if yondu's arrow
could do that I feel really good arrow
was probably capable of a lot more than
what we see in the movie because when
they were doing that there I was like
why didn't they just do that because it
can cut through metal they've shown that
at least I'm pretty sure they happen in
Part two when it's going through like
all the different rooms they probably
cut their ships how does it react in
anti-gravity do we know that have we've
seen it in a nine at maspiro yes I don't
think in this movie and I don't think a
person either maybe it doesn't work in
space maybe not my favorite parts of the
house
are the Kafe endings I love weather in a
cafe and having their banter and
Superman and Batman are always there
that's the kind of movie I want them all
right you know like really fun spin on a
big MCU or DC you move you do it like a
pure covetous matter or almost like the
office style and just have them like
sitting around because they're not
fighting and being superheroes that were
7 they have to have down done I would
wish there was a way to parlay like
those Thor sketches they put out over
really into some kind of series where
like you just watch your heroes do the
post more I feel like that what was that
Vanessa Hudgens show where she was a
coward Shirin yeah you know in the
superhero world what were the things
that you thought needed to be taken care
of that we never really saw and
obviously you need someone to do her job
certainly that didn't an ask me that is
a shitty idea I commissioned here
[Applause]
[Music]
terrible idea
marry no no three-part harmony how you
guys know we gave you the know your
wavery job no no accents no puns no
singing we should go on a date sometime
first we're going to a comedy club when
we get to do the comedy then we're going
to karaoke carry a baby we'll be hearing
that like before travel this video Rosa
para my dear now she pledged on patreon
allows her to be part of the Google
Hangouts which she has been a part of
and now she has taken on a lot more work
and cannot be a part of them anymore
saving more lives which is sad because
she was the only female who can be a
part of the Google Hangouts everyone
else on patreon is a male who could be a
part of the I am sad that we won't get
to see your beautiful delicious sexy
face all the time talking to you is one
of the greatest things I've ever
experienced you have four lovely
daughters and one of them who likes me
and prefers me over John and I'm happy
about that a child love you know it is a
really touching thing and I know your
kids hate me but that's alright you know
as long as they love me you know how
Rosa found us how did she find you she
found us just outside man yeah so you
punch me ma'am what danger John to me
it's the first time that's happened
three roses favorite yeah yeah we in
fact we coordinated with crescentin yeah
to make a special shirt of that the
posters that his friend makes those
posters are incredible yeah your poster
in particular it's very flat is the only
one who has a shirt and only one in the
world has a shirt of John Humphrey MVP
that said John sine drove it down so
cool
Mary really nice things for your friends
we try we try to make it like every on
yeah it is nice to receive and give back
good way to give you guys a little more
credit than you're giving it no no no no
no no
we used some of that money to make the
shirt actually read a negligee you
should increase your pledge yeah you
should really want that money John and I
know how to receive compliment when I go
to midnight I imagine the inside of your
car so that's usually where you're
skyping in from Oh
all right guys a little subscribe to how
it should have ended please do yourself
a favor I'm sure you've heard of them
yeah we're down the rabbit hole and just
watch 100 of them are you guys telling
that directly to me or to your viewers
to subscribe to how it should have ended
Harry we're not going to leave this
video until we see you learn to enjoy
your life with your cat at home
subscribe to the real real X I'm ready
to subscribe to you guys subscribe you
talk to the camera follow John and death
and follow yourself at Perry Nemiroff
and P Nemiroff on Twitter I don't think
that's possible it is possible can I
create a separate account just to follow
myself and I love it I like all my
videos and prevention